hello welcome to breakthroughs from
science mission I am sadashiva pi and
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of July 14
let's start first we will discuss a
paper published in nature on the role of
recombinant fgf one in treating diabetes
why is this paper so important role of
fgf one in lowering blood glucose levels
is not clearly understood authors
demonstrate acute and chronic fgf one
treatment lowers glucose levels in
different mouse models authors also show
that recombinant fgf one lowers glucose
levels probably through insulin
desensitization let's look at the data a
single injection of fgf one was
sufficient to attain normal glycaemia in
severely hypoglycemic genetically obese
mice and the effect was dose-dependent
glucose lowering effect was also
observed in another genetic model and
that induced or base mouse model fgf one
had no effect on blood glucose levels in
normal glycemic Chow fed mice but radius
glucose levels under fasting conditions
thereby dissociating that glucose
lowering effects of fgf one from its
effect on food intake also FG ofone
seems to be unique in its ability to
lower blood glucose levels compared to
other family members indicating
specificity of fgf one alternate day
injection of fgf 14 36 days also lowered
glucose levels while the body weight did
not change f2f1 treated mice showed a
market improvement in insulin
sensitivity as measured by insulin
levels and insulin tolerance test
triglyceride levels were decreased while
I cojen content was increased in livers
after five weeks of chronic treatment of
g of one how does ft of one ladies
glucose levels in structure so toss in
that is s TZ induced diabetic mouse
where in drug caused destruction of
insulin-producing beta cells fgf one
alone failed to lower blood glucose
levels indicating that ft of one is not
insulin mimetic also pretreatment of HTC
minds with FG f1 markedly enhanced the
glucose lowering effects of exogenously
supplied ensuing the FTF one dependent
increase in metabolic clearance rate was
severely blunted an insulin secretion
was inhibited by summit of statin to
discount the mitogenic effect of fgf one
proliferative activity of truncated FG
one showed decreased glucose levels
similar to one truncated fgf one similar
results were also seen in diet-induced
obese Mouse the FJ of one receptor
knockout mice failed to lower blood
glucose levels indicating the action why
are the receptors these results
conclusively prove a role for fgf one in
lowering blood glucose levels next let's
look into a paper published by audit HIV
and colleagues in cell authors
demonstrate that starvation leads to
inheritance of small RNAs for three
generations why is this paper so
important starvation health effect on
future generations and mechanism of
inheritance is not clearly understood
the study shows the inheritance of small
RNAs for three consecutive generations
following starvation authors identify
gene targeted by transmitted small RNAs
left three offspring also show an
increased lifespan authors star C
elegans for six days and looked at the
small mrnas
this figure shows the identification of
STDs that is small rnas targeting
specific genes in different groups more
than 500 predominant up and down
regulated small rnas are 22 g rnas and
out of those 88 were down-regulated
mRNAs 22 dwek GST jeez that were
upregulated in their ancestors following
l1 starvation were also upregulated in
statistically significant manner in the
f3 progeny in comparison to the fed
ancestors potential target gene enriched
were found to be related to nutrient
reservoir activity in addition small
rnas may indeed preferentially target
germline expressed genes which are
twenty-seven percent up and eight
percent down regulated authors also
found that inheritance of ninety-three
percent HD G's is dependent on ide for
as shown in this figure authors also
found that offspring third generation
from stabbed great-grandparents show
extended lifespan in comparison to the
ones that were continuously fed over
generations others came up with a model
that suggests that a transient trigger
l1 starvation is memorized by the
generation of an example of small RNAs
which are then available to target mrna
in ensuing generations in the absence of
the original starvation trigger thank
you for watching science breakthroughs
from science mission